uh so without further ado let me get
into it
rancho high school a perfect reminder
that a prosperous future begins with our
children
encouraging their growth and development
and providing them with the tools to
become the next generation
of visionaries i just had a chance to
visit with some of the students
right across the hall here there was
four kids in summer school
so when i went to school you were in
trouble when you went to summer school
right and i had occasion to do that when
i was in school
but these kids do it because it helps
them receive
credit sooner than later gets them
prepared for college
or whatever trade they they choose to
or whatever direction they choose to go
but luckily this morning i went in there
and they were making sourdough bread
so rancho is a culinary
technical school it includes culinary
and that's part of their curriculum and
and they told me all the nuances of
sourdough bread which i didn't know
there was i thought there was one basic
ingredient with it but they
they informed me i was wrong and so they
walked me through that
but it was it was important for me to
see their enthusiasm
i asked them what it was like to learn
in a pandemic it was encouraging i hear
that to hear the optimism
despite the fact that our governor
denied an entire generation of students
months of critical education
social interaction and activities like
sports music and theater
it was a reminder that our children want
to be optimists they want to learn they
want to succeed
and they want to make the world a better
place
our governor opposes school choice and
has failed to provide a plan to reduce
class size as governor i will block any
tim
to force critical race theory on our
public school children
we can teach our children to respect
each other and treat everyone with
dignity
we must bring back a focus on trades so
nevada can attract good paying
manufacturing jobs and we must do a
better job of keeping our best and
brightest
right here in nevada it is easy to
criticize the governor for copying the
world's
the worst policies of some of the most
liberal governors
in the country i think the one right
next to nevada
and there is no denying that steve
sislek is the most partisan governor in
nevada history
but anyone well nearly anyone
could campaign simply on being less
isolated
and less partisan our campaign is
different it's about ideas it's about
returning some vision
collaboration communication and
leadership to the office
we have a governor and legislature
focused on protecting their own party
guaranteeing single party rule so they
can introduce state income tax
raise your property taxes and advanced
public policy
that would make bernie sanders blush
that was actually a funny line
did you get that one see rancho got it
single party rule has led to higher
taxes new regulations and erosion of our
individual freedoms
so let me draw a line in the sand i will
veto any new taxes
that let the legislature sends my way
i think that bears repeating again
i will veto any new taxes
this important part here folks and it
brings us home
with law and order single party rule has
led to politicians focusing on felons
rights
prioritizing criminals over victims
weakening penalties for crimes and
handcuffing the police
that isn't sustainable behavior for any
state let alone a state that relies so
heavily
on tourism while portland seattle and
baltimore
gave in to riders looters and vandals we
instituted a zero tolerance policy
for violence let me be clear i will
always stand up for the rights of anyone
to peacefully protest
but if you intend to bring harm to our
people our communities or those visiting
our community you will face the full
force of the law
[Applause]
our short and long-term prosperity is
dependent upon the rule of law
and on a fair and honest judiciary that
respects and protects the constitution
without bias or partisan influence
the rule of law should extend to our
election process we should all want open
and secure elections where everyone has
confidence in the results
we must undo the reckless partisan
policies out of carson city
and replace them with election law that
is transparent
honest and fair let's demand voter
identification
eliminate ballot harvesting as well as
repeal the new practice of mailing
ballots
to people who do not request them
i support a bipartisan election
integrity commission to oversee our
elections
and guarantee fairness i support a
nonpartisan
or bipartisan redistricting commission
so voters have a better chance to let
candidates of their choice
rather than being boxed into districts
designed to benefit a particular
political party
i'm a strong supporter of the second
amendment now that just
isn't rhetoric right mike
just isn't rhetoric i've carried a gun
every day for more than 30 years
in the army as a cop and as your sheriff
i will always support the rights of
law-abiding citizens to responsibly
own and carry guns further i am the only
candidate in the race who made and kept
a promise to eliminate clark
county's gun registry
[Applause]
while political candidates and
committees profit from the dysfunction
of federal government states are forced
to deal with the problems
america is a nation of laws that must be
followed followed with
borders that must be protected but we're
also a nation that should welcome
legal immigration working with a system
that rewards
rewards rule followers but as a zero
tolerance
policy for those who don't
when the aclu and a liberal california
judge
liesel for those who don't know that's
my attorney sitting there
she's the one that protects my back
when the aclu and a liberal california
judge denied us the opportunity to use
federal database to determine the true
identity of criminals
we adjusted and dedicated more internal
resources
dedicated more internal resources to
identify
to identifying and deporting violent
criminals
i need that to sink in a little bit um
there's
been a lot of rhetoric out there
that i have created a sanctuary of
jurisdiction
and that is absolutely not true what we
did is adjust
moved resources and addressed the
problem
to move forward versus backing up and
say we raised our hands and gave up
it's important for people to realize
that
america cannot have a dignified and
respectful immigration policy without
defending our borders
protecting our citizens and removing
those who wish to do our nation
and our people harm one of the things
that has made nevada great
is our wide variety diversity
and leaders who focus on creating
opportunity for all nevadans
nevadans believe that if you work hard
and play by the rules that you can
create your own american dream
as i but the current governor chooses
the winners and losers
this isn't right and it's time to take
it back our state for all nevadans
as sheriff i relied upon a multicultural
advisory committee to work through
community and law enforcement challenges
to help us better understand the sources
of conflict
and diffuse difficult situations
creating a committee isn't unique in
politics
but listening to its members is
at metro everyone has a seat at the
table but in carson city that just isn't
the case
that ends the day i'm sworn in
the metro multicultural advisory
committee
in mac has written or changed policies
addressing derogatory social media
our gang database recruiting and
diversity training
those are just a few of their
accomplishments the important piece is
we didn't refuse to
listen we collaborated for solutions
i will set a clear vision as governor
and my administration will advance
towards specific goals consistent
with that vision relying on our
leadership
experience and commitment of a diverse
group of nevadans
interesting piece i received recently
somebody close to
the current administration is our
governor has failed to meet with her
his leaders and i think it's important
piece to provide leadership and vision
and direction that that has to occur
that simple task
is really troublesome to me and
it's one of the biggest failures
associated with leadership so it
bothers me to know in and i can see the
direction we're going as a result of
that
i think it's important for you know i
grew up here went to school here and
after serving in the army
came back to back here to serve and
protect nevadans
i've been a proud to stand up for the
victims of crime and stand up for those
who wish to do us harm
i am a proud veteran a former beat cop
and the chief executive of an agency
that prides itself on being tough
and accountable sink that in tough and
accountable
i will stand by my record as your
sheriff for the last seven and a half
years
in my last 33 years on the police
department
on how our police department has
performed protected the community
and i believe a fantastic job
[Applause]
this is an important piece folks i have
been elected twice as a conservative
in our state's bluest county
i have never compromised our principles
to get elected and won't do so now
today i'm standing here to announce my
candidacy for governor
because if we don't put an end to the
single party rule
eroding our state of the values laws and
opportunities to make nevada great
we won't have a lot left to fight for
for those who don't know i'm sheriff joe
lombardo
i'm running for governor and i hope you
will join me in taking back
our state